废話不多說趕快進入我們今天的第二個環節我們跟老律這個EVE的訪談那我們現在先看一下今天的第一個問題就是我們任何一個同學比如說想加入一個團隊他肯定會很關心這個團隊的技術氛圍到底是怎麼樣的對吧那我們想問一下就是老律這邊你們團隊是怎麼去打造這樣的一個技術氛圍的呢我覺得我們團隊技術氛圍最大的特點就是開放就是我也是建議大家能盡量做到
就是大家都把事情講直一點講白一點公開來說不要指著眼影尤其是技術上面的東西我覺得沒有什麼是不可以說的我覺得如果想要建立這樣的技術氛圍主要還是說能夠做到盡可能多的大家能去做分享就這個分享不僅僅是比如說是技術上的分享更多的比如說是別人有提什麼意見或者什麼什麼的
那我觉得应该团队里面建立一些比较正向的反馈就比如说别人给你提意见那你应该能够虚心接受吧如果说如果说是比较正向的意见或者说你觉得是有道理的意见那就应该就应该发现这其中可以可行的一些改进的地方那尽可能早的去落实一些别人提的意见然后呢技术氛围上我觉得差不多就我觉得只要能够做到开放
然后大家都能够接受别人的意见我觉得这个就可以嗯差不多就这些明白就我我总结下就老驴的意思就是从一个就是两个关键词吧一个是开放对吧另外一个就是我们要多做一些分享对没错没错没错好的好的然后呢我们再看一下第二个问题啊就是我们现在其实比较关心因为看刚才在直播间有很多同学在问一些其他的技术站的问题呢我其实比较好奇现在比如说老驴你现在是在
哪块你遇呢然后你是怎么去构建你整个技能数的呃我其实最开始的时候我是做iOS的和大家一样都是做iOS的呃后来我转了后端我基本上不太做iOS呃所以我其实有经过蛮大的一个转变我在过程当中我写过代码也其实种类非常多哈那个最开始写oc然后一些写过swift然后又转回了oc然后
然后又去写了Java又写了CGI加其实我整个过程当中我看我觉得因为很多同学会对比如说要上手一个新技术或者上手一个新语言会比较的会比较的呃有排斥心我觉得没有必要其实只要大家能够自己去动手做其实就可以很快的学会这些东西所以技能数其实我觉得最好的办法就是尽可能呢自己去动手做那只要动手做了基本上
用不了太多的时间因为你可以通过在做的过程中去学习别人的代码也好去学习别人已经做过的一些事情也好就很快就能够了解一些具体的技能需要的东西对然后专注的领域我最近比较关注的是和3D渲染相关的东西嗯就这些啊好的好的那其实我刚才也看到我们直播电影同学说是多电对可能整个核心的速度就是我们先动手去做
不要管那么多对吧你想要的东西没错ok好的行那我们再看一下第三个问题啊就是我们经常会做开发社开发同学都是很讲究效率这个东西嘛就是老律这么有一些比如说你觉得可以去提升我们开发效率的一些开发工具可以推荐的啊因为前面我看那个直播那个群里面有人问这个问题就是前面我讲那个流程里面有哪些工具是
是在用的我講一下就是那個結合這個問題講一下那最就是設計上就是在做設計的時候一定要在線文檔我之前沒有提過做那個CodeReview的時候就是設計和那個設計審核的時候都是在線文檔然後那個做CodeReview的時候就常見的比如說GitHub也會有這些功能任何可以做那個代碼審核的都可以沒有局限
然后最后那个上线审核我有写是用那个电脚键或者是用战线文档都可以所以其实我觉得对我来讲提效的开发工具最大的其实是战线文档对我来讲就是战线文档过去几年我觉得它解决掉了我沟通成本里很大的一块所以我个人觉得推荐的就是战线文档任何公司出的战线文档都可以
好的好的大家大家也没有听到就是我觉得对我们其实我也想讲一下就是这种提效的开发工具啊就大家呃可能做作为开发者可能很多开发者会忽视掉文档的一个价值对其实我觉得就是刚才老律讲这个在线文档其实我觉得确实是因为可能你要把文档写好其实相对来说可能比写代码还要更难一点因为你要在中间做很多设计嘛对吧老律对没错没错
可能你要先在你写这个文档过程其实就是你在构思你的整个怎么去设计而写代码它其实是一个机械性的动作对 没错 没错其实你整体如果流程都已经想得很清楚的话写代码真的是水道取成其实应该我觉得你花的时间我个人觉得是1比1就是花在设计和最后的实现上应该是1比1因为如果说你在花在写代码时间里很多那说明之前没想好
就是你有很多代码可能你反反覆覆地再去做修改嗯对的确实是因为代码的结构要改修相对会比较困难一些文档的结构改修会简单很多对对对对对确实好的那我觉得这个问题还是比较价值的就是大家多多去写一些在线的文档好的那我们再看一下第四个问题啊就是大家都会很关心的一个问题就是比如说老律宪谈的没有还在抗择然后
你们这个面试要求是怎么样 大家要重点去考察那些方面我记得我前段时间我还看到过那个Google有在上海招LS engineer我还是记得当时老司机也发过 我还在周报里也发过我不知道现在还招不招 我今天应该等一下可以再看一下就是我记得当时他们招那个团队是NAS做那个智能加区什么的
我们公司就是看我觉得北美公司基本上面试都还是要求主要的点还是在第一个是算法第二个是设计上就这些东西我觉得还是挺挺挺重要的其他的话我觉得就还好那所以一般来说你要面一些北美国海外公司的话去做一些利利扣的那些算法体系是一定是必要的除此之外我印象里应该也没有太多其他的要求那
因为我们电视手不太就北美公司不太喜欢问一些很基础很几层的那些问题那些问题其实没有那么重要其实比如说你们做iOS开发基本就知道一些比如说GCD啊这些东西就可以了没有必要说去深究说GCD的原理是什么这是怎么实现的我觉得这个也没有太大意义吧所以所以我理解我们还是更考一些相应的
就类似这种专业课的基础功底对不对像对没错没错对对可能到最后来说都是大到至简我们最终还是要回到基础来对吧对没错没错就我觉得好像我印象里国内有些面试它会问一些很底层的东西那我觉得那个问了好像跟工作也没啥关系吧这个我要赞同就是对于国内来说
确实刚刚我看直播间的同学在说就是这个很卷真的很卷对可能但也是我觉得这是因为互联环境确实蓬勃发展然后竞争很激烈的一个原因我觉得这个可能是一个比较大的原因嗯ok行那我们再进入下一个问题哈对我觉得这个可能也是个比较有意思的问题因为有有同学可能会对在国内工作会对国外工作有一些
想法嘛,那想了解一下比如国内工作和国外工作有没有什么样的区别我先讲一下,我没有在国内工作,所以可能我要说国内工作的区别可能不太讲得很具体,因为我只能通过网上看到的人来讲没关系,你来讲国外的,我来讲国内的,我对国内工作很好,行行行,基本上我觉得国外工作就是我觉得
首先第一個一般大部分公司應該不會有996吧這點是這點是我可以確定的那其他的話我覺得整體的流程或者整體的節奏我覺得是肯定要比國內公司慢慢主要是在因為就跟我前面講了他有一個流程之後呢他要走流程走流程一定會慢一些所以呢我覺得相對來講他的可能整體工作節奏會比較慢
產品上限可能會沒有像國內那麼頻繁比如說上限那個功能然後反而不去改動可能有可能就是上限了之後基本上是之前因為在設計上也花了很多時間可能改動會比較小也不太會去做改動然後就可能去做其他的功能就類似於這樣的一個工作節奏你可以分享一下你的雅雯我其實
我觉得说实话应该我也不用我具体分享我觉得在直播间同学应该会有很多感触就其实我听完老律讲的这一系列的东西之后我只剩下两个字羡慕对国内确实因为整个互联网本身发展就是也相对偏偏晚嘛然后也在一个就是现在尤其又到现在到了整个时间的默契了就是一些红利器已经过了那很多东西都会到一个深水区那深水区就是
在国内又面临有这么多研发的情况下那公司肯定是会卷嘛这个卷是一个所有团队都会存在的一个情况但是因为我个人其实已经做了我从我作为管理者的角度来讲吧因为我可能做了带了一段时间的听那个团队了我觉得最主要可能还是我觉得这个听力的非常非常重要在国内我不知道我可能也不算不算那个什么就是我觉得听力的的角色很重要就是
你这个Timmy的他是不是一个会聪明去做事情的人这个其实蛮重要的嗯这个其实在国外也挺重要的我觉得这个我觉得不管在国内还是国外就是有能你的你的一辈子当中如果能遇到一两个好老板那真的就是你的福气说实说这个说难听点啊就是遇到一个好老板真的是可欲不可求的对对Timmy的这个角色非常非常重要因为有的Timmy的可能
其实说白了听密的就是上传下达这是个比较重要的角色嘛就是很多听密的他如果能把他的向上因为他向上管理是要管理上上级对他期望的嘛如果他能把这个向上的期望做好管理的话其实他是能对下属做一定保护的对他的同学做一定保护但这个我觉得还是大家还是可以多看一看吧我觉得主要还是看一看包括大家其实去面试的时候看这个
公司的氛围所以一定要去好好地跟这个大家不要觉得呃公司面试我就是面试的时候就是面试我而是你要也反过来去面试一下你的这个team leader看看他是怎么去思考一些问题的对啊不好意思team leader就是team leader不好意思我的发音可能不太标准team leader okay好的那我们再继续讨论下一个问题啊对就是也会有很多的想问啊就是如果我想出国工作就是有没有一些什么样的建议到底这边啊我觉得
主要是两条路吧第一个是如果你真的想出国的话你先想好你到底有没有做好打算比如说如果你是有老婆孩子的那你就要考虑的更多的是老婆孩子的如果你都已经想好那就两条路要不是出国读书要不就是比较常见的要不就是就是在去一些国内的比如说国外的厂然后呢在在过几年比如说因为有些国家会有工作签证的这个需求所以你需要等那个工作签证尤其是美国还有工作签证要
要抽签那要抽签的呢重签率也不是很高所以就需要等如果你抽到了工作签的你就可以转过去嗯我记得微软啊或者说google啊就这些大厂基本都是可以提供这样内部的转组的就可以直接从国内转出来或者说你就呃对就反正我觉得主要就是两条路或者说有些公司他会直接在国内招人但他招的比如说新加坡啊或者说呃
加拿大有些职位因为那些有些国家他不需要工作先生比较好搞那这种情况下就可以直接面试就相对比较容易所以我觉得基本上就是两条路吧要不读书要不就是转组或者是直接去面对一些不要工作先生的国家的一些搞明白好的非常感谢老律的建议ok 那我们再看一下我们今天第七个问题啊就是对于老律你所在的
公司来说就是如果是要想想出国工作的话公司会提供一些什么样的支持呢首先就前面讲了就是我会帮你去做那个工作宣传抽签那抽不抽到这个公司就没办法了然后呢就因为有一些场呢是在全球各个国家都会有一些兜兜一些那个办公室那他会你想转到一些欧洲国家那也是可以的因为有些欧洲国家他的工作群众会比较好那对
这公司就会提供那些签证啊就是一些在一些移民啊这些上面做一些支持可能有些公司还会提供一些搬家费吧那其他的话基本上也没有太多吧或者可能你要学些外语的话公司里面有些有些公司会提供一些学外语的一些课程啊或者说一些经费啊什么的可以让你花
哎这个这个还挺不错我觉得最后那个英语这个部分我觉得还是蛮不错因为可能尤其很多从国内想去国外同学可能在这一块呃虽然有一些训练可能也没有很好的一个环境嘛那如果公司有这样的知识其实还是能帮助大家更快的融入整个社会社会的我觉得对对ok好的如果还是这样如果对老驴公司有兴趣的也可以这个部分是一定不要错过的好吧ok那第八个问题啊这也是我觉得可能看
老李比如说你觉得对你的团队成员你比较看上他哪一块的品质呢我觉得我觉得是主动性就是说我更希望就来团在团队里的人能够比较主动的去学一些东西就这个主动性指的是比如说不一定是要我把所有东西都安排好了交到你手里才去做更多的是你能主动的去发现一些问题可以来沟通或者说可以来做交流
但是希望能有更强的主动性我觉得这块我比较看重好的对 听好我觉得这个确实是刚才讲的努力这个点其实是非常非常重要的对主动应该是主动这个点是非常非常重要的确实我们也不太喜欢一些比如说很多事情都要我推着你走的这种是这个是非常非常累的可能我推你一下你走一步推一下走一步这个确实太累了合作起来对 没错OK行 那我们再看一下
这个问题我觉得是一个比较有趣味性的问题了就比较轻松的一个问题就是老爷在这边就湾区有没有什么比较有意思的建文比如说湾区这边肯定有很多这种科技前沿公司嘛就是有没有碰到一些比较就是你觉得印象蛮深开有意思的这种东西我感觉湾区就是一个因为这个湾区这个地方就是有点类似于只有公司只有上班的一个地方
这个地方基本上你每天看到的周边的人也基本上都是互联网公司的员工比较多就是马龙比较多然后比较有意思的建文我觉得基本上就是每次看那些大公司的比如苹果的发布会啊或者说谷歌发布会它里面有讲一些比如说有讲到一些录啊什么的然后你就发现啊原来他讲的东西就在你边上或者有说你看那个NVIDIA的那些发布会里面那些演示
你會發現原來這個路就是平時我上班的路就類似這樣你會有一種森林奇境的感覺除此之外彎曲我覺得是一個挺無聊的地方說實話挺無聊這個地方這個有點出乎意料對OK好的這個問題我們不展開討論了我們去看一下下一個問題因為我們時間也不早了我們到時候可能要回答大家的問題那最後問題吧就是公司證明有沒有什麼特殊的福利
我觉得Google嘛Google的话就很多湾区的公司我记得那个那个谁之后那个linkedin他们就是有一个有个嘉宾是linkedin的嘛就是有很多的湾区公司它是有免费食堂的然后呢有些公司的食堂会比较好吃有些食堂不太好吃但是那建于是免费的所以就不挑了哈那个我记得linkedin的食堂很好吃
之后那个林的那个还分享的时候可以追问他一下食堂好的没问题但是他可能比较晚我看他应该是在倒数第二期可能得到七月份去了可以可以没问题我觉得这些福利还是比较有意思啊对对对这个食堂口味的问题确实挺还挺有趣的行那我们我们选一下直播间再挑选两个问题吧因为时间也也不是那个特别
特别早了我看一下我先看一下我们看直播间有没有什么收集到什么问题好的OK我在这里挑几个吧对第一个就是如何去提升这个人效如果是业务区动开发的话一堆活怎么办我觉得这个就是牵扯到你前面讲的那个听leader作用一个好的听leader是要学会有就是要有取舍的不可能把所有的业务
都給做了它還是需要做取捨因為你在人數有限的情況下不應該是通過壓榨下面來完成這些業務如果說真的覺得有些業務它的這個優先級比較高的那你應該就優先去排那些任務而有些優先級比較低的比如說那些可有可無的業務我覺得Tim Lee的作用就在這就是應該是把那些
能夠跟上面好好的溝通 溝通清楚說為什麼這個東西現在可能重要性不是那麼高那我們應該花更多的時間去把另外那些任務做完我覺得還是要就是Tim Lee的作用還是在這個地方要體現出來明白好的對我剛才看到一個問題啊就是我覺得好像直播間應該被提了很多次就是關於35歲焦慮這個問題剛才同學問說資本主義有沒有35歲焦慮就是在國外這個35歲是怎麼樣的一個看法
35岁这个我一体感觉上应该是没有这个说法因为公司里面年纪大的其实挺常见的就是尤其是尤其是做一些很底层技术的那些五六十岁的头发花白的也是很多大把的就是这个我觉得可能还更多因为还是看说你做的东西到底是什么因为确实有很多的比如说你做做那个OS的Colonel那些东西
那肯定是你经验越多才会越吃香嘛就还是要看你做的东西如果是你做的东西就是很业务化的东西那确实可能经验上也没有那么的重要那这个时候你可以考虑的是比如说要不就是转管理要不就是去转一些其他方面的东西嗯那我刚想再多问一句国外团队就是比如说像我们这种中国的人去在国外团队去转管理这个难度高吗
難度是有的主要我覺得難點還是在前面我講的溝通上因為英語如果不是你的母語的話那你在溝通上是天生有劣勢的但管理這個東西又是極其看重溝通這件事情尤其是要不就是文字上就是寫郵件要不就是在線上開會或者說在線下開會的時候的語言上的溝通這個都是非常吃這個語言上的能力
所以转管理我觉得对沟通上还是要求很高的明白好的 那我们今天就先聊到这里吧因为我们时间基本上已经快接近尾声了那那个先非常感谢老虑的这个分享和我们这个一对一回到我们这么多问题